[Music]
from powerful performances to uplifting
speeches we are one family and we need
you we need your voices the one world
together at home special brought out the
music legends to unite the globe during
the corona virus outbreak really caring
and giving back it's beautiful the 8
hour concert raised 127 million dollars
to help the World Health Organization's
effort to fight the pandemic I care so
much about all the medical workers that
are putting their lives at risk for us
right now Lady Gaga who curated the
global citizens event kicked it off with
a joyful rendition of Nat King Cole's
smile Taylor Swift saying soon you'll
get better a personal song which is an
ode to her mom who's battling cancer
[Music]
really good friends the musical icon was
somber throughout the performance but
got through it like a champ you have
music TV you know people artists like
that that's what's inspiring from her
lit backyard Jennifer Lopez covered
Barbra Streisand song people
[Music]
[Music]
and the singer got emotional by the end
of her performance I miss you
John Legend and Sam Smith pulled off the
perfect virtual do way proving these two
powerhouse singers are exactly what we
needed during this time
[Music]
lizzo sent us over the edge with a
passionate performance of Sam Cooke's a
change is gonna come
[Music]
Baili Eilish delivered a soulful
rendition of Bobby hebbs Sonny while her
brother Phineas killed it on the piano
[Music]
also giving us the fields Kacey
Musgraves who sang her song rainbow
[Music]
during her emotional performance the
singer shared inspirational photos of
people's rainbows which inspired her to
sing her hit song
[Music]
kamilla Kibeho and Shawn Mendes are
serious couple goals the Quarantine
lovebirds joined forces to sing what a
wonderful world the one world together
at home event also brought out the
Rolling Stones and if this special
couldn't get any more legendary cue
Charlie Watts playing air drums The
Beehive was buzzing once Beyonce made a
surprise appearance we are one family
and we need you we need your voices your
abilities and your strength all over
this world and Oprah shared some words
of encouragement while praising the
front lines I tell you we've all
appreciated health care workers but
never like now they truly are the best
of us and their compassion and their
true acts of service is a call to action
for all of us we have to care we have to
be aware but we have to make a
difference and that's just what Celine
Dion did
the singer joined forces with Lady gaga
Andrea Bocelli and John Legend for a
four-part harmony with famed pianist
long-long
[Music]